-Quavo!
You're up first.
Come over here, my friend.
-Ooh.
-Pull the mic.
Let's see what you get, bud.
-[ Indistinct ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Okay. You got
"Nonsense Karaoke."
Here we go. You got this.
-♪ This is Nonsense Karaoke ♪
♪ This is Nonsense Karaoke ♪
-You're gonna have to sing
a well-known song
but the lyrics have been
replaced with total nonsense.
-Oh.
-Let's see what song it'll be.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I like that.
-Oh, man.
-It'll be in the tune
of "Get Low",
but it won't be the words
at all, okay?
So whatever lyrics you know,
forget about it.
These are all nonsense.
-Okay.
Just go over there, and it'll be
right on the teleprompter
in front of you. Good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's go, Huncho.
♪♪
-Yes, sir!
-Pickle brine.
-At the mall.
-♪ Fuddruckers ♪
♪ Lemons and limes ♪
[ Laughs ]
-♪ In a shawl ♪
-No hands!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How'd you do that?
What in the what?
How?
-Whoo!
-How?
How?
How'd you do that?
♪ I bought a Kindle
at the mall ♪